been doing a lot of sort of bigger
picture planning and thinking about the
david pakman show because after the
election we are going to have
far fewer stories about the election
since it'll be over and a lot more time
to really explore other areas that are
important to us that are important to
our audience and of course depending on
whether it's donald trump or hillary
clinton that win in november we will
have either
a very moderate democrat and we will
want to be actively pushing for more
progressive bills and laws and ideas to
be passed by our lawmakers or we will
have an absolute lunatic unqualified
individual in donald trump and then
it'll be pretty clear the type of
messages we'll have to be putting out
there in order to try to protect
ourselves as much as possible from the
damage he could do
and in thinking about that i was really
thinking about the history of the show
and how far it's already come for people
who don't know this program started as
once every other week in a basement
radio studio in northampton
massachusetts and over time because of
the support we've received from our
audience it went from once every other
week to once a week to twice a week to
four times a week and most recently a
couple of years ago to a five day a week
show
and every time the program has had more
support from the audience we've grown it
and every time we've grown it we've
obtained more support from the audience
and it's been a very very effective sort
of feedback loop which i hope continues
now many people want this program to end
uh we i get emails from them all the
time look at our youtube channel look at
our facebook page look at reddit
uh that may happen right if the support
we have from our current audience goes
away if everybody up unsubscribes on
youtube and stops watching our clips if
all of our members decide to cancel
their memberships i can guarantee you
that this program will end because there
will be no more money to fund the
program i have faith
that the good people out there that
understand the importance of programs
like this are going to continue to
outpace the trolls and the haters and
that the program will continue to go and
a lot to grow and along those lines i'll
very quickly tell you about the best
ways to support the show the first one
being this may come as a surprise to you
because i really don't mention
membership very often it is this thing
called membership and you can go to our
brand new website
which by the way people absolutely love
i'm hearing out there and people tell me
all the time trust me on this this
website is finally winning again
davidpakman.com
membership you can sign up for
membership we have a cool slider that
gives you inspirational messages the
higher you drag it when you're choosing
your level of support that is the main
foundation for supporting the david
pakman show but there are other ways if
you ever shop on amazon.com
you can go to davidpakman.com
amazon that'll redirect you to amazon
everything you buy will send us a little
kickback you can also interact with our
social media platforms one of course
being the discussion forum on reddit
which you can get to by going to
davidpakman.com
reddit you can also like the show on
facebook where we now have surpassed 50
000 likes at facebook.com
davidpakmanshow and then you can follow
both me and the show on twitter the show
is at twitter.com
davidpakmanshow we are well on our way
to 100 000 followers there and you can
also follow me on twitter
twitter.compacman
not doing quite as well there uh closing
in on 50 000 twitter followers and
lastly
instagram.com
david.pakman we post pictures there we
do sometimes post
instagram only discount codes for
membership on instagram
anything you can do to support the show
is of course hugely appreciated most of
this stuff doesn't cost you any money
and it's just showing that there is
buy-in
and to the hundreds of thousands of
people that are connecting with us
across all of our different social media
and distribution platforms thank you
the show is not guaranteed it could end
tomorrow if all of our supporters pulled
their support i remain confident that
that is not going to happen